it has been too long and i am getting
too good at identifying what these woke
commercials are trying to sell my
producers have found the three wokest
commercials i don't have a headache i'm
just preparing they tell me that there
is some theme some vague theme to these
commercials i'll try to guess that too
you know this video is brought to you by
ring the wonderful ring alarm and ring
video doorbell
we'll get some more from them in a
second first let's roll the commercials
it's like an immigration thing
not a car that's like an old car
selling uh
maybe a mexican thing like
sombreros or something i don't
is
the minute it comes out that they're gay
they do the brokeback mountain thing
that's
a little on the nose guys whatever
company this is
is this like a messaging app maybe maybe
that's the tie-in
like some communications company
uh
it's gonna be like a communications
company i think like a phone company or
a tech like a tech platform
what did i say
what did i say
[Music]
is it reddit i hope that it's reddit i
don't know i don't know if reddit has tv
commercials
[Music]
you are no longer my son get out of my
house
be
[Music]
[Music]
what about the reddit logo i was totally
ah
what a fake out what a total fake out
it's they make me think that i got it as
it's as though i said it's a tech
platform and you saw reddit i was like
man i did it and the only thing that
threw me off was i said wait reddit
doesn't have commercials
i should have realized it's the gay
doritos now i want partial credit i said
maybe it's a mexican thing like maybe
tacos doritos is pretty close
do i get do the judges
am i getting no i'm asking for too much
okay first your last
that is
that is very unfortunate yo quiero
pointos give me extra pointos for that
okay let's get to number two
a harmony of flavors a week in crossword
land taking a swipe at love or sex or
something breaking the binary the magic
of numbers the big impact of a small
hobby queer love and color heritage and
rituals new york times
because of the weird fonts imagining
harry potter without its creator alter
egos that bark the joy that looks like
new york times
and it sounds completely insane like the
new york times how to talk through the
heart stuff
[Music]
yeah yeah that was too easy the people
there looked and sounded like new york
times people the content was completely
ridiculous like all new york times
content and the font size come on give
me a break guys i don't read the new
york times but i play wordle that's just
fancy talk now i'm sure everyone knows
about the ring video doorbell by now
because i've been telling you about it
for many years it's an amazing doorbell
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door whether you're in the house
whether you're at the office maybe
you're on a beach on the other side of
the world did you know that ring
also makes an alarm yes ring makes an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring best
of all you can easily install it
yourself it's so easy to install even i
can do it i need to hire contractors to
change light bulbs but even i can
install this takes like 15 minutes
you can get all the sensors for motion
for the door for everything i love ring
i strongly recommend you support ring as
well protect your home protect your
house from freeze fire flood go to ring
dot com slash michael mich ael get a
great deal on a ring alarm home security
kit today that is ring dot com slash
michael i really appreciate ring for
supporting my show for supporting these
videos for supporting us for many years
you should go support them too it's a
great way to protect your home and your
family all right so what i'm batting 500
right now
totally nailed it on that last one
give me the tie breaker give me the
third woke commercial
[Music]
is that blurry
there's something to that
oh is it like that that was the lord
[Music]
[Music]
is he going to be gay
are they going to make him gay if they
did
yeah uncle alberto yes muy gayo now
because we all have to be gay now for
some reason
isn't this another chip company
tostitos maybe
[Music]
how come only one of them looks dead
nunca estarde para turno gayo doritos
again okay do i get credit because i
said tostitos you've got a credit for
that okay that's great so i i i just
didn't i didn't believe that we could
get two doritos commercials in the same
group but it's the exact same type of
commercial notice what they say here at
the very end hashtag pride all year
hashtag orgulo todo el ano you know how
much i hate to say i told you so but i
called it it used to be
there was pride day pride there was a
pride parade
and it was a joke by the way it was gay
guys who would dress up like leather
daddies and they were kind of making a
joke out of the whole culture and
talking about the pointing to the most
eccentric aspects of being
a gay guy
then it became this very serious somber
this is my identity thing then became
gay week then became gay month that was
june then one month wasn't enough it
became two gay months june was pride
month then october was lgbt lmnop
history month so now you had pride sixth
of the year and i said but before long
it's going to be pride year it's going
to be pride constantly all the time
pride pride
pride pride and what did doritos do
they did that
they they did that the according to alex
jones the government turned the frickin
frogs gay and doritos turned uncle
alberto gay all year long
but that's fine whatever i won the game
i i'll take my wins when i can get it
send in your favorite commercials we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]